entonces queremos encontrar esta suma la
suma de menos 50 más menos 44 más menos
38 más y así me voy a mantener sumando y
sumando y sumando hasta llegar al 2000
38 ya esto le voy a sumar 2044 pausa
este vídeo y ver si puedes evaluar esta
suma por ti mismo
bien ahora vamos a trabajarlo juntos y
para eso pensemos un poco qué es lo que
está pasando aquí tenemos a nuestro
primer término y si te das cuenta para
pasar del primer término al segundo
término lo que hice fue sumar seis
unidades sum es seis unidades y del
segundo término el tercer término
también sume seis unidades sume seis
unidades por lo tanto parece que me voy
a mantener sumando seis unidades seis
unidades seis unidades seis unidades
hasta llegar por ejemplo a este y
observa que de este a éste lo que hice
fue sumar seis unidades esto quiere
decir que cada término consecutivo es
seis veces mayor que el término anterior
por lo tanto la suma con la que estamos
trabajando en esta ocasión es una serie
aritmética es decir es una suma de una
secuencia aritmética cada término es
seis veces mayor es decir seis es la
constante que se suma a cada término
siguiente nosotros sabemos cómo obtener
la suma de
aritmética sabemos que si estamos
sacando la suma la suma de los primeros
en términos de una secuencia aritmética
o buena dicho de otra manera si estamos
evaluando los primeros n términos de una
serie aritmética entonces esta suma será
el primer término más el último término
entre 2 esto entre 2 es decir me estoy
tomando el promedio entre el primero y
el último número
esta suma entre 2 ya esto lo
multiplicamos por la cantidad de
términos y bueno de una manera rápida
podemos ver que aquí tenemos al primer
término este es a 1 y este es nuestro
último término es decir este de aquí va
a ser a subíndice n pero la pregunta
aquí es cuánto vale n es decir con
cuántos términos estamos trabajando y
para resolver esto bueno
pensemos en cuántas veces tenemos que
sumar 6 a menos 50 para llegar
hasta 2044 bueno pues si me tomo a 2.044
2044 ya esto le restó menos 50 cuanto
voy a obtener y bueno observa que esto
tiene sentido porque es lo que quiero
encontrar es qué tan lejos tengo que ir
desde menos 50 hasta 2044 observa que lo
que tengo que hacer es aumentar primero
50 para llegar a 0 y después 2000 44 más
para llegar a 2.000 44 por lo tanto
tengo que tomarme la suma de 2.044 más
50 que esto va a ser 2000 44 más 50 más
50 lo cual es 2.094 tuve que caminar
desde menos 50 hasta 2044 2.094 unidades
para llegar al término final es decir
estoy incrementando 2.094 ahora si estoy
sumando de 6 en 6 en cada término
cuantas veces tengo que sumar 6 para
llegar
a 2.044 desde menos 50 o dicho de otra
manera
cuántas veces tengo que aumentar 6 para
obtener un incremento de 2.094 y bueno
esencialmente lo que tengo que hacer es
tomarme la división de esta cantidad
entre 6 es decir tenemos que dividir
esta cantidad entre 6 y 4 va a ser eso
bueno pues si agarro 2.094 ya esto lo
divido entre 6 que voy a obtener bueno 6
caben 20 3 veces 6 por 3 es 18 entonces
20 menos 18 eso me va a dar 2 bajó el 9
y lo voy a poner aquí y bueno 9 por 5 es
30 ya me pase así que cabe 4 veces 6 por
4 24 24 y si me tomo la resta de 29
menos 24 me va a quedar 5 y ahora voy a
bajar mi última cifra que es el 4 lo voy
a poner por aquí y bueno 9 por 6 54 así
que menos 54 y esto me da
pero de lujo muy bien entonces para ir
de menos 50 hasta 2044 lo que hice fue
sumar 6 349 veces entonces sumo una
primera vez 6 en este momento dos veces
aquí 6 en este momento y así me mantengo
sumando hasta llegar aquí en este
momento estoy sumando 349 veces 6 para
llegar al 2000 44 y bueno si te pregunto
cuántos términos tenemos aquí
seguramente vas a estar muy tentado en
decir 349 pero ten cuidado porque
realmente tenemos un término más observa
esta es la primera vez que suma este 6
esta es la segunda vez que sumas de 6 y
así sumaste 6 349 veces pero todavía no
hemos contado el primer término entonces
tenemos el primer término ya este primer
término luego le sumamos 6 una vez
después dos veces después así hasta 349
veces por lo tanto si contamos todos los
términos
349 términos después del primero ha
dicho otra manera tenemos 350 términos
en esta suma por lo tanto ahora sí
podemos decir que en vale
350 y ahora puedo sustituir esta n en
esta fórmula que tengo aquí si yo quiero
obtener la suma de los primeros 350
términos de bueno esta sucesión
aritmética esto va a ser lo mismo que el
término inicial lo cual es menos 50
menos 50 más el término final que es 2
mil 44 2044 todo esto
todo esto dividido entre 2 y bueno a
esto habrá que multiplicarlo por n pero
n ya sabemos que es 350 está del lujo
así que vamos a hacerlo la suma de los
primeros 350 términos va a ser igual y
cuanto sexto menos 50 más 2004
42 mil 44 50 es 1994
estás de acuerdo bien y si ahora divido
en 1994 entre 2 ok está más fácil
dividir 350 entre 2 350 entre 2 es 175 y
a 175 lo voy a multiplicar por 1994 así
que en 1994 por 350 entre 275 y bueno la
multiplicación de esto va a ser igual ok
para eso mejor voy a traer por acá mi
calculadora 1994 por 175
348 1950 así que dejan notarlo esto va a
ser igual a 348 1950 y bueno aunque ya
llegamos al resultado si lo que quieres
hacer es escribir esta misma suma que
tenemos aquí en una notación signan
entonces se va a ver más o menos así
sigma notación sigma y que vamos a hacer
la suma de quien desde acá igual a 1
hasta acá igual a 350 nos vamos a tomar
los 350 términos de bueno de esta suma
que tengo aquí y la suma textos va a ser
igual a la suma desde acá igual a 1
hasta acá 350 de quien bueno nos tomamos
el primer término menos 50 ya esto le
sumamos quien le vamos a ir sumando 6 le
vamos a ir sumando 6
can menos 1 veces k menos 1 veces
recuerda que es k menos 1 veces porque
no queremos que el primer término se le
sume 6 lo queremos a partir del segundo
término y si vas variando la cama vas a
ir obteniendo todos los valores que
tenemos aquí y para el último término
que tenemos aquí lo que hicimos fue su
marca 349 veces así que en el último
término si sustituye es aquí la cama vas
a obtener 6 por 349 menos 50 y así
llegamos a 2.044 aquí lo tienes esta es
la serie aritmética escrita en una
notación sigma ojalá y todo esto lo
hayas disfrutado